i met your new double o she's a
disarming young woman
i get why you shot him
yeah well everyone tries at least once
hello to you both and congratulations
i'm a longtime bond fan so i'm extremely
excited right now
uh so first of all i wanted to ask you
daniel um i just watched in addition to
watching the incredible film being james
bond the documentary and they they
showed sort of the last you know 16
years later the last shot when you're
walking down this hallway this is the
last shot not the last shot in the film
that you shot though as james bond um
and then i think he walked out and gave
a speech can you sort of talk about like
we don't see your face but walking away
what were those moments like for you
get me a drink
now
where is my drink
why is it taking so long
someone must be mixing me a drink
somewhere please i think along like
those lines yeah
i don't know i can't i tell you the
truth i can't remember well you did
shoot it a long time ago but yeah it's
probably i mean you know the thing about
you ask anybody uh um who shot a movie
thinking that the last day is going to
be some sort of big celebration or kind
of like yeah punch in the air moment
that it's always an anti-climax it's
always a sort of that was a you know and
that was no different in a lot of ways
because it was backlot at pinewood
two o'clock in the morning
rain
cold it's just like it's just like it's
like you know is this it this is this is
the way we're going to go out and in a
way it's sort of apt i thought great
this is kind of how the way it should be
what was the big surprise was the fact
that everybody came to the set and all
of the people came out the offices and
all of the heads of department came down
and suddenly i'm surrounded by all the
people i've been working with some of
them for 20 30 years and that that was
that was different i was still thinking
about where the drink was
lovely wonderful lashana i absolutely
love your performance in this film
when we first meet your character and
this is not a spoiler because it's been
in the trailers you sort of pay homage
to the classic bond girl because you are
you know we think you are one thing and
then you flip the script
and that's sort of a lot of what you
know the franchise has become i wanted
to if you could just sort of walk me
through
playing that scene and sort of playing
the sort of the one side and then
flipping it and then i think you spoke
about like the first few times you acted
opposite daniel you you had to check
yourself for a second you had to sort of
say oh my gosh like
stay in it yeah yeah i mean that moment
was
a lot of things in one for me because i
was shooting in jamaica i'm jamaican so
that was already weird i was staying in
a hotel not my family and that was weird
um
it was
yeah the first scene which is a really
important scene in the big scene right
literally first day plunging straight in
right yeah
in
like we we didn't even have much time to
rehearse the the day before so like
there was a lot to it but also
i i didn't want to think about
i didn't want to think about the history
of the franchise i just wanted to have a
conversation with bond and she nailed it
anyway so you know thank you
i mean
i mean i was thinking my mind was racing
that day i just thought
how do i i don't want to make it too
heavy like you just said i don't want to
think about the past i don't want to
even think about the future and i think
about actors and what that means and oh
but then there's me gosh my journey into
the industry like literally my mind was
working on 100 and i had to just put
everything down even the sides i had to
just throw away at one point and think
you you know it it's in there you have
prepared for know me know me is going to
come out um so just let her be and let
her have a really honest conversation
with bond which she did and it's such a
powerful scene
every time i see it i think gosh she's
she's rich she's serious about this
stuff she just is
on a whole other level in her own lane
and um yeah it was beautiful to be able
to really reflect women in the franchise
but also really nice for her to have her
own stamp too daniel you've always since
you played since the beginning you've
really held true to you've stuck to your
guns to not to use a you know
pun from the film but you've stuck to
your guns creatively in terms of what
you wanted for the franchise and you
know you've you've changed the franchise
in a lot of ways so i'm wondering for
when you came when you decided to come
back for this last film
was the ending always what it was going
to be was that something creatively that
you decided um or was it in flux it's a
long process and uh you know we we kind
of uh
we had ideas i've had ideas since the
very beginning and i kind of want to you
know i wanted to sort of that you know
bring um
i want you know i wanted to bring all
that we'd sort of put into the past four
movies and try and round them off in
this movie that was that was so
important to me and the fact that i've
been given this chance to to tell a
story from the beginning was like you
know i mean that's
that's the deal i mean it's one of the
biggest difference i think with the
movies i've made is that we've had a
link from the beginning and we certainly
try and tie that link from the beginning
to this one shauna we never find out
what your drink of choice is you're a
double o his his is you know a martini
what is yours
literally i like
chamomile flowers literally
sparkling water sparkling water
i know racy
with lime
oh my gosh put it on the front page um
i didn't know if i wanted to know me to
drink or not i i was thinking about how
she views bond and things she's heard
over the years known over the years how
she's learned him through a document and
um i i wondered if she she
how much she respected or disrespected
didn't respect him because of how much
he drinks do you know what i mean not
like he drinks all the time but like
that he drinks all the time and she's
like well how are you focusing on work
if you're constantly drinking very
well always wondered
i've always wondered daniel if he was a
better agent tipsy or sober
he's never drunk
he noticed
literally he's got he's got quite a
quite a constitution um
listen i think it's a gag it's a running
gag i love the fact
that someone that's a very nice russian
journalist a few years ago made me a
chart
and it was all the bonds and all the
drinks they've had and i'm at the top
and i was like yep that's great and i
feel like it's a sort of nice gag
because of course it's ridiculous nobody
can drink that much net and function and
do all these things but he's james bond
it's just like you know and i'm not
advocating people to drink at work for a
second it's a really bad idea
but it's it's a it's it's it's fun it's
just fun that's all have you seen
drunken master
what's that there's a concrete film
called drunken master he relies on drake
to be better there's drunken histories
as well
that part
yeah yeah yeah watch it you'll see what
i mean
his name is saffin
and what does he want
revenge
me
i know a little bit but anyway i just
wanted to say how beautiful uh a film
this was in terms of this relationship
between madeleine and bond and there was
a scene that really struck me and it's
not a spoiler but you're you're sort of
like holding each other and you're
looking at each other and the way
there's something about the way he
touched you i said to myself watching it
this is how a man really in love touches
a woman
and you it's very hard to act something
like that so if you could kind of talk
about how you did create that intimacy
with daniel that we get those real
moments on screen that i completely
believed it yeah it's um it's true that
in no in the inspector it was um
it was not that uh incarnated in a way
incarnated
and so i really wanted this time
uh when i
you know i read the script and i wanted
like my goal
was to make this relationship
believable
and uh i was uh i i wanted like
not to to to think about the fact that
we were like in a james bond film but
really like
a love story between a man and a woman
and uh
and and so for that
carrie was great because he wrote those
those uh scenes you know
those very intimate scenes and
and uh
and uh yeah i mean i was i was yeah they
were great i mean they were great to
shoot and
and i think i think they were like also
like
it it was important for the audience
yeah to to understand
the the real bond
that they have together yeah i've been
using that phrase today too i'm just
going there everybody seemed very bonded
in this movie
um
so
the fact that this is the first woman to
come back and have a two film arc
what do you think is so special about
that connection between madeleine and
bond and and because the first one was
so shrouded in mystery who she is but we
see a lot more of her
can you speak about how does she feel
about him is he the love of her life how
does she see him
yeah i think yeah i mean yes she she is
he is he is um
the the the
[Music]
i
it's it's um
it's interesting because um
i think that
daniel you know gave gave so much depth
to his character
and
so
i so we needed to have
you know uh uh
in front of him like
also
a more complex woman
and um
and so and um
and so
i i'm
so that's the reason why at the
beginning of the film we see her
with her mother
and we understand that she's like james
bond in a way
uh very damaged
and uh dave in a way shared the same
like uh
the same problems i mean he was he's an
orphan we all know that he's an orphan
and and i am too
uh so i think that's that's why they
they are so connected it's because they
they understand each other
um
and
yeah it's uh
it's it's it's also
amazing because it's the first time that
we see a born girl
who
who's just uh vulnerable it's
vulnerable and and and we get to
understand
her childhood you know and where she
comes from like the first scene it's
only it's her
i mean it's her and her mother and and
then it it's really
i think it it gives like just more
reality you know and more uh it's it's
yeah it's uh and more um
it's more
yeah real and real
what um as an actress bringing those
emotional scenes to set i think there
were some set photos where you were just
you know in between takes super
emotional so um if you can talk about
how that was for you bringing
bringing that emotion and and how
challenging it was for you
it was it was very it was very
challenging
very um
emotional and
also because it it is daniel's last
james bond
and that when you saw the pictures i
think it's uh they were taken the day we
shot the the final scene
and it was very intense
emotionally it was the end of the
shooting
and uh i was just uh
overwhelmed you know and uh
yeah and it was um
i mean it's it's uh it's difficult to
act you know it's not it's not an easy
thing
um
and yeah it was i i felt a bit
i i would say i felt the pressure
and i and i really wanted to give the
best yeah
well it's a beautiful performance um
there's something really gorgeous in the
beginning of the film and this is no no
spoilers but where your character and
daniel sort of write something on a
piece of paper and then burn it just to
let it go what are sort of like a couple
of words that you would use as sort of
like a beautiful memory that you take
from working on the james bond films
oh it's such it's um
you're gonna make me cry
no no it's it was it was it was
extremely emotional like even now you
know it's like we were doing this
promotion a year and a half has has
passed you know it's it's uh
no i feel i feel extremely um
grateful and it's been like an amazing
experience
you know it's not only work it's it's a
it's a human experience and working with
all those amazing people you know
and also carrie the the director
you know i'm very
thankful to him because he he gave me
this
this part and and baba
boccoli the michael wilson the producers
i mean
i feel extremely lucky very very lucky
and um it's something that i will
cherish you know
those memories all my life and it's
really
it's um
yeah it is it is uh
yeah james bond is a funny it's a big
part of my life sorry you you just made
me cry so thank you very much for being
so sweet and thank
i'm just cheering up this is supposed to
be james bond a fun escape and we're all
crying
we both eradicate people
to make the world a better place
i just want to be a little
tidier
saffin is amazing
he is so good now i heard that you and
carrie that you actually started talking
to him about this role
even before bohemian came out and that
you would send him tapes with different
iterations of different iterations of
saffin's voice you were kind of working
out different accents how many different
sort of accents if you could talk us
through that and can we release those
tapes can we see the romney
don't know if it was taped so much as tr
yeah maybe we were trying it's so long
ago that i can't remember who was tapes
or if i was i was traveling back and
forth to london i was still shooting mr
robot so
we were coming up with ideas carrie
carrie thought of a few different
countries that and specific time periods
of those countries he wanted to hear so
i would give him those and
there were many moments where i thought
to myself listen we always go to a
certain country for villains or you know
we've heard of the stereotypic villain
voice so i
i would start to amalgamate certain
countries and voices that i thought were
um
were interesting you could kind of guess
what they might be
but
you know we live in a world where
whatever is very foreign to us can
sometimes feel very scary so uh the more
the more of uh
i i felt you couldn't pin him down i
thought the more threatening he would be
oh that works well speaking of scary i
know there's something you've talked
about that sometimes you take the roles
that scare you the most what about
tackling stuff and scared you that made
you go oh it scares me i got to do it
there's a element of him where he can
just detach from from his own any type
of
empathy or morality in order to just
brutally exact his will and you know
he's straight to the point the guy
is no bs as far as i'm concerned i wish
i could be more like that
yeah well i don't know if you i don't
know if anybody wants to be more like
him maybe just a little bit this much
maybe maybe i know you crafted your own
villain for this there are so many
famous bond villains if you could have
like an all-stars and go toe-to-toe
against a past bond villain and see who
is the baddest baddie who would you go
toe-to-toe with who would sapping you
toe-to-toe with
i have to say there's one specific scene
in casino royale with mads mikkelsen and
daniel craig i think you know what i'm
talking about and i would hate to ever
be in daniel's position for that scene
yes i actually thought maybe we were
going to talk about javier bardem's
scene yes being on the receiving end of
a seduction scene with javier martin but
you know yeah you know that i mean that
was a very unique take and uh you're
talking about some of my favorite actors
uh
what javier did what mads did i mean all
of
all of the guys that daniel's had to to
go up against matthew and of course
kristoff have just been such fierce
adversary so it's just great to find
myself in a long list of talented men i
admire well you are among them and you
top the list and watching that scene i
want to know for you as an actor when
you come onto a franchise the first time
you and daniel locked eyes you've seen
those piercing blue eyes it's difficult
to uh to pull yourself away i remember
the first time he came and saw me and i
was in my makeup chair and just taking a
break and i caught him by surprise but i
could tell he was a little taken aback
by the prosthetics and of course on set
when i saw him in action i was a little
taken aback by
just how james bond he actually is how
james bond is he
he's
he is a commanding presence he's a great
leader he's very altruistic selfless
um you get this feeling that he's really
out looking out for the greater good
daniel for the film for the actors and
for the crew and of course
james bond for the world at large you
just almost said it like bond james bond
that was very good you know typically in
the past we've seen some villains like
stroking a cat there's even youtube
videos with just that
what is saying like is it his herb
garden and would you ever could you ever
see yourself being inspired by stuff and
then having your own garden robbie it's
the stupidest question no it's not i
mean didn't everybody uh so many of us
started gardening over the last couple
years um what i love about that zen
garden it is just so iconic bond if you
know the early bonds they're designed by
ken adams uh adam and his sets were
i mean they are go go down in cinematic
history and we have a production
designer's name's mark tildesley and he
tried to pay homage to those sets
and that was a breathtaking moment for
me stepping onto the double 07 stages
and seeing my own
poison garden i mean what could be more
bond than that i guess a cat
okay last question the most bond thing
of ever james bond has his martinis what
does saffin drink
saffin steals uh james bond's martinis
and
i suppose if he wants it shaking then
he'll just get there and stir it and
vice versa just really throw him off and
sprinkle a few herbs in from the garden
in there possibly possibly you're
getting close
harder to tell the good from bad
villains from heroes these days
first question to you both is you know
there's a famous story about how when
daniel craig found out he got the role
of bond he was in a supermarket getting
groceries ditched the groceries went and
got martini mixed got properly sloshed
so for each of you first i'll start with
you jeffrey
when you found out you were coming back
after so many years what was the first
thing that you did and then billy first
time in a bond film um
well uh you know i i've heard that story
um
i heard a different story did you hear
that story
daniel and i actually had a few drinks
together when he got uh when he got the
gig because we were doing a movie
together i wasn't with him at the
grocery store but i definitely joined
him for some drinks after that
uh so it's been you know for me
at the time i didn't know i was going to
be a part of it i was you know they they
kind of invited me on a little bit later
but what was uh what's been cool about
it
is to is to be there for this you know
for the start of this thing
with him
and then to join the thing and you know
round it out at the end here is uh is
pretty gratifying i don't i don't you
know i was
i was uh obviously um
excited to come back and kind of you
know finish off the the ark so i don't
remember what i did but
i remember i showed up in jamaica and
and found billy there
hey buddy you shut up
for me you know that you know daniel
might have had his martinis in the thing
but for me the real the real joy was to
be with billy oh buddy jeffrey you're so
sweet
so when again when they got they didn't
finish the story i was the bartender
making their martinis at the time
yeah billy billy billy was the
celebration for all of us i think no
you're sweetheart you're asking me i
really love you jeffrey
oh i love this quote-unquote bond
between the two of you i hate even using
that word oh i love the pun i love it
very
very strong i was weirdly i was actually
on backpacking trip in vietnam standing
outside a address i don't know why this
address was zero zero seven there's no
reason the address should have been zero
zero seven but when i got the text about
it
yeah because it wouldn't just be seven
it wouldn't be zero zero seven
that is wild yeah that is very
serendipitous jeffrey you have now
worked on the greatest trifecta
marvel dc and bond how would you
describe bond as being distinctly
different from those other massive
properties what is the the
the feeling on set that sets it apart i
don't know if there's well i'll tell you
i mean there's a there's a really
uh
kind of modest feel on set and and that
simply because there's so many of this
of familiar faces that work on
these projects um in front of the camera
and also behind the camera um they're
you know they're crew members that have
worked on on you know bond films for
decades
so it's a really um you know kind of
like family vibe on the set that's
unlike any other
any other project that i've worked on
and bond is singular um you know yeah
i've worked on some large franchises but
you know bond is uh
there's there's no
there's there's no bigger fish in the in
the pond
than than bonds simply because you know
it's uh it's lasted for
how many decades now was it seven eight
decades now um
so
it's uh there's there's nothing like uh
there's nothing like this thing the
others are are really you know wonderful
um
franchises to be a part of as well
um but yeah you know bond is uh is is in
some ways separate from all of them
billy you were brought on and there's a
really fun scene in the beginning where
daniel's always making fun of your smile
like he says he smiles a lot was that in
the script was that written specifically
for you because you are
you know you have a great smile i think
they were making fun of me to tell you i
don't know
look at this cheeky look at this cheeky
smile
the entire script was written was
written around
billy's
lovely smile so that wasn't an improv
that was a daniel improv that was
written in the script yeah that was
definitely in the in in the script um
uh and i just you know you'll have to
find out
more when you see the movie i guess uh
there's a lot of mystery here there's a
lot of you know there are a lot of coded
kind of mysterious things here
and billy's smile might be uh
you should have asked about his nipples
though and then that
they're working they're working
i wasn't gonna say but hey if you're
pointing it out jeffrey
thank you for that i think i think they
cut that out of the script though
unfortunately
when our secret finds its way out it'll
be the death of you
you can imagine why i've come back to
play first question i want to ask you
right right off the get-go the opening
of the film you know
you you sort of have talked about how
you through the kitchen sink and
everything you gave everybody the
classic bond tropes they want but the
opening feels very different than a
traditional bond film it's the sort of
the first time we don't really see james
bond doing the james bond thing it
almost feels like a horror movie can you
discuss sort of like the thinking behind
that and and why you wanted that element
in the beginning um
well we'd heard madeleine tell this
story inspector about what happened in
her childhood home and it was a it was
an anecdote that we'd been throwing
around that could come in different
parts of the story you know we even
thought about putting it somewhere in
the middle
and then it sort of occurred to me you
know about three months before we shot
it that it actually felt like a really
good opener it's like who we why don't
we play with the the ideas of trust that
exist or these themes of lack of trust
that have existed since casino royale
show a little bit of this anecdote which
you know in the canon the fans will know
but it's a great teaser and then set up
this you know the villain out of this
these first four minutes and it does
have elements of horror which i think
maybe are
outside of the normal bond film
but it's you know it's still it's the
exhilarating form of horrors i think it
does still come into the thrilling
aspect
talk about thrilling um
the stairwell scene
i
almost i had such a visceral reaction to
it that i almost couldn't watch it it
was that interesting oh really
yeah and i think that's what's so
beautiful about the way you shot you
know you shoot things people are talking
about you know how you shot the famous
scene and true detective and this sort
of has that same one or element to it
can you sort of just talk about how
difficult that was to pull off and and
working with daniel and crafting that
scene you know before i about a week ago
when we're doing press you know and no
one had seen the film but they asked me
if i'd if you know if they could expect
stuff like we did in true detective and
i don't really want to talk too much
about you know those kind of things
because i like them to be a surprise i'd
like you know for you to experience it
rather than be waiting for that that
section to happen so i think the craft
side of things is always fun when you
know especially with daniel like just
kind of like conceiving of like how
we're gonna handle certain sections of
the film i think the idea
of the audience's
um reaction to it is as important as you
know the the story and the the execution
and the execution's part of how the
audience can react to it so it's all
it's all part of the same sort of uh
if you want to think of like when you're
cooking a meal you know it's all part of
the spices you want to put in there and
the layers of flavors that will make it
the most sort of exciting and thrilling
experience for an audience so i think
that was the the goal is is that
you know every 10 minutes you're you're
in this story and it just keeps
progressing and pushing and propelling
forward and doesn't really
you know give you those a full respite
to kind of tune out and think about
something else it keeps you hopefully
engaged all the way through and that in
that moment as we're getting towards the
end of the film it's like we're we're
propelling them to that final section so
we need that last little bit of
adrenaline i think injected in it what
uh important bond elements like very
bond elements did you want to bring into
this film that we're sort of like easter
eggs nods and that too what we consider
classic james bond i think um on her
majesty's secret service and you only
lived twice
were two of the kind of classic bond
films that really informed
style content
themes
characters uh in this film those are two
i think of my favorites and i i think
you know that they really um
um
uh
they're they're if you think about
relations within the bond canon those
are very close relations to this one
which lent itself to the line about
having more time from on her majesty's
secret service exactly that that famous
line then yeah you know martin campbell
did two
two bond films with two different james
bonds would you want to come back and do
another one obviously we're not going to
have the beloved amazing daniel craig
but is that something you're interested
in i know you've talked a lot about as a
storyteller wanting to do you know
what's inspiring and challenging you
moving forward so would you want to come
back and do another
well nick i think it's exactly that it's
like what when that if that were
opportunity were to come in the future
where am i at my creative process is it
something i would want to take on is it
a new challenge is it something that you
know fits the moment in time of my life
these films are really
you know they're all encompassing it on
all engrossing when you're working on
them they take up every aspect of your
life you know it's like monday through
monday so
um you know i'd have to be at a place
where like i had that time i can really
commit and throw it because i wouldn't
want to do it unless i could do it right
uh without spoilers how much uh was
daniel instrumental how much were you
instrumental in creating the final act
for bond uh was that something you
always knew
where he was going to end up the final
act
of this film or was that in flux we
didn't know where the where's and hows
but we knew you know how he wanted the
story to end and we knew how we wanted
his service to end you know in terms of
like
a relationship with mi6 and the double o
program we knew exactly how
all that was supposed to end up so
that's kind of like that was an end
piece we didn't have the beginning i had
a few middle pieces that you know
barbara and michael and daniel really
wanted to hit and characters the new
characters they wanted included so those
were things i knew about sort of if you
think about like building blocks and
coming up with the story but the
circumstances around everything were
completely you know part of the creative
process on this one
the past isn't dead
thank you for an incredible
series i mean this is my favorite
franchise it always has been since i was
a little girl so thank you for
continuing to carry it on so i'm going
to jump right in i have a ton of
questions uh first of all the questions
for barbara daniel has talked a lot
about that moment when you called him
and you said those famous words over to
you kiddo and i just thought that was
such a refreshing
character say you got the role their
agent calls it it was so unique is this
your catchphrase are you going to say it
to the next one
and uh no i i
that was that was just for him i mean it
was such a crazy situation because we
were trying to
connect
and um he was in baltimore shooting i
was in london
and somehow i was on the street corner
and he was in whole foods in baltimore
uh not exactly how you imagined to uh
you know to impart this news
and uh you know we were on the phone and
i said well over to you kiddo and uh
the rest is history i mean
he's been magnificent 15 years of
extraordinary
uh dedication to this series and you
know he's just magnificent and you're
actually leading me into my next
question because i do really love him
and i've loved so many bonds in the past
um
if you could maybe michael talk about
something that we have we don't know
that he has
shown his level of commitment on screen
but i watched the documentary and it
really hit home the level of commitment
and how few actors i could probably
count them maybe on one hand in history
that have had that level of commitment
so if you could share maybe a moment
that sort of awed you where you were
just like wow when you saw him as you
were on set well i i thought it was
amazing that to prepare
we've all heard you know the actor
prepares but he actually
changed his body
you know changed his whole
body
in the most amazing way you know he he
lost a lot of weight around it lost
inches on his waist and gained weight i
mean it's the most amazing
transformation i've ever seen
so right then you know uh and and when
he was
when he was making the film very often
you know you see
actors that love to go out in the
evening and
[Music]
have a drink after work and all that he
would go and do more exercise he'd
take a very modest to dinner and then go
to bed
extremely
early you know and he was so disciplined
he was
he just took the work so seriously
you know he said he's a most disciplined
actor i've ever seen he you know he
always knows his lines he's always there
he's always on time he's very committed
to what he's doing uh he
takes whatever free time he has he'll go
out and rehearse with the stunt men
the level of commitment
is unbelievable
he's also an amazing person
now besides and that comes across i mean
the humanity always comes across on
screen no matter how good an actor
somebody is and i think that's why he's
endured and been so endearing i found
myself
i was you know i know you had the
premiere simultaneously i was in la
watching the screening at the same time
and i had chills when i
the moment that it went from black to
the first opening shot goosebumps
there's this le this franchise just
brings that about that level of
excitement i want to know for both of
you at the premiere
what is that like for you after you work
on these films for years and years and
years to hear the audience reaction does
it ever surprise you or they laugh were
they you know what was that moment like
for you this time around
well it was you know relief really
because it was the first time
you know we've had a public performance
of the film you know it's very important
to us that we
do it at the albert hall
that we show the film in england where
the film was made we had many many of
our crew and cast there
and you know the thing about daniel's
portrayal of this character has been you
know it's very much about service and
personal sacrifice
and you know after the terrible 18
months that we've all come through we
really wanted to celebrate obviously
daniel but also
everyone else who has you know helped us
get through the pandemic and so it was
important to us that we had frontline
workers there healthcare workers
um and we're doing a similar thing in
the united states because
you know
we really want to thank people for
everything they've done to help get us
through this terrible time do you have i
know ian fleming had his do's and don'ts
for bond do you have your own do's and
don'ts i i don't think we necessarily
have a list
but i'm but we instinctively know where
the limits are whether they're where the
red lines are
and
uh it's interesting barbie and i don't
sit down discuss it but
we both come up with the same reaction
when we get to a point where
we say
that isn't going to work i think you
look at you're like stealth you look at
each other and it's like this unspoken
thing we don't even have to look at each
other
[Laughter]
you know i i it's it is it has become
instinctive over you know
we've both worked with cubby and uh
we've been at this a long time so we
have a pretty
pretty
pretty good instinct about what to do
but how far we can go
i
for the first time found myself watching
this movie in the past i'm looking for
different things in a film of course you
want the big set pieces
but the for the first time i looked at
the character and i went i just want him
to be happy
that has a lot to do with the heart that
daniel brought to it i'm curious was it
like is it the chicken or the egg when
you cast daniel
he brought a lot of different elements
to bond that we hadn't seen before so is
it that you find the actor and then he
brings that and you sort of evolve with
the character or were you looking for
that
sort of grittiness or a different
approach well we had you know we had the
great fortune to get the rights to
casino royale um
which you know my father had wanted to
make originally
so i mean that was really
that was the um
the opening to be able to transform this
character to to re reset him and uh
in order to do that we had to find an
actor who
who was up for the challenge and could
you know really explore the inner life
the emotional life bond and and daniel
was the obvious person i mean he's just
such a magnificent actor
and you know i think
you know what he's done over the past
five five films has been extraordinary
and you know the
the audiences love him and they seem to
be responding extremely well to this
movie so we're very very grateful oh
yeah i mean undoubtedly um i know you're
not thinking about the next james bond
to next year i don't want to know i hope
you surprise us again but is there any
element of james bond you haven't
explored i mean i hope so that's for the
future you know hopefully we'll find
something
that we haven't explored before but uh
we've been mining an awful lot over
these past few films so let's hope
there's still some stuff left for the
future
yeah and i think we're also in a time
where
you know there's going to be so many
characters off this film that are going
to pop paloma i loved her know me
q
would you ever potentially consider a
spin-off we're in this era where
everybody wants to explore universes
like whether it's tv a streaming whether
it's on the big screen one thing i think
has made james bond successful is that
it's not in a lot of characters you're
focused on one person that said and
that's what's made it successful that
said would you consider it i think we
feel like you do that the success of
these films is is the central character
so we haven't done that in the past
uh and i don't think we have any plans
to do it in the future but you know who
knows well i think michael you maybe
said it that you brought the kitchen
sink to this film you you gave us the
bond tropes but you also gave us
something fresh can you talk about maybe
one of your favorite tropes that you got
to bring to this film in terms of set
pieces or or just giving the fans what
they want and what they love about james
bond that classic james bond
well i think one of the things is that
we try to give the fans
something
they may not expect something that'll
surprise them
but be within
the universe james bond and i think with
daniel we had the opportunity to do that
because he was an actor who could
develop those ideas and you know from
seeing the film
um
how
we were able to um bring
a lot of new elements to it
put bond in a lot of situations the
personal ones the family ones
uh
have him face
a woman 007 as a replacement uh
have him face
uh m who is
has um
a big issue to hide and deal with and
and the villain
and a existential threat to the world so
you know um i think we put them through
a lot of things here and uh and
some i don't think
are were anticipated by the audience
right wow definitely that's for sure i'm
not going to say anything more but the
first time that i saw jay uh daniel in
casino royale and he comes out of the
water were you paying homage to him in
this film we saw the shower shot we saw
him a couple very sexy shots was that
kind of bringing it all full circle
absolutely i mean it uh
yes the shower scene was one i was
particularly uh
fighting for um
and he looks great
if we don't do this
there will be nothing left to say
i have to finish this
nope
[Music]
you